continental tire coaches corner brings
us Mike sous-chef ski head coach
obviously Duke and Team USA in oakland
tonight to play China the reception for
Kevin Durant will be a little bit better
tonight in oakland that it was the last
time around coach joins us now good
morning coach how are you yeah good yeah
i'm really excited about our team and
excited for Kevin tonight to make his
debut in front of the Golden State's
hands and he got a great reception
yesterday what's a function last night
or late afternoon and was as he should
be warmly welcomed you just jumped in
with coach speak right away it like it
doesn't say hello it's just more of a
alright and we're going to do one of
those interviews are we gonna I mean
like you got your game face on right now
you know I not that I don't want to be
you know warm and cuddly with you but uh
I do have my i said my game face i'm
going to do yeah and uh we're getting
ready for a staff meeting and and then
the team meeting but now i'm excited
about the the team I yeah this is it's a
short time and to see our guys working
so hard and they get along so well I'm
excited about the team we might be in
real and we will use tonight to get a
little bit better so none you know when
you're in this your your kind of all in
yeah so to speak and so I kind of have
the blinders on and yeah you only have a
short time it's a little bit over a
month and I've done yet we want to win a
gold now and real who's the player that
seeing up close seeing maybe on a more
regular basis surprise you so far the
most
it's a good question which is unusual
for epic reviews with me and they're
actually a few because I don't get a
chance Edie's guys on TV but I don't get
a chance to see him in person so first
of all DeAndre Jordan is such a good
player they had a great athlete great
guy and to see him Ron defend holy
mackerel yeah he is really good I've
never I haven't seen Paul George in two
years when he had that horrific injury
you know in Las Vegas at our one of our
camps and you know he's got he sewed are
good and defense tremendous and the same
thing with Jimmy but work oh well we had
not seen those guys so you know I
thought they'd be good there all better
than what I thought and and as far as
guys go there just terrific guys good
group just a really good group to work
with he's very athletic we're very
athletic so you know defensively we
could be we could be a very good
defensive team we've shown a willingness
to want to do that first two games the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience